nous allons décider du bateau mais on
nous a mis un petit peu loi donc c'est
une émission c'est une émission il faut
ça qui fait le boulot monstre de
florence
donc cette émission a été transformé en
émissions sportives notamment ici si
scandale il fait du patin rocco siffredi
qui étaient des films x
marie idrac études et aux épines sur
quoi vous j'espère le dire
bon alors marie sara on va vous faire
une hyper dur donc vous allez voir la
lumière bbc mais voilà elle a baissé
moi je vais arriver
il monte j'avoue le mot sida ça vous
baisez que la lumière baissée la lumière
pour qui un petit peu d'intimité s'il
vous plaît serge khalfon voilà c'est
mieux comme ça sent mieux et vos yeux
sont top dans cette lumière là là vous
êtes même année saint lô co ça va
après qu'une ambiance qu'il ya des
changements au redoublement bravo
longuet bon bah on a voulu vous invitez
parce que si j'ai bien compris marie
sara c'est votre dernière saison
ses manières saison passée s'arrête
quand à arles en septembre en septembre
lors d'une corrida n'a d'yeux et là je
commence donc ma dernière saison
vous voulez pourquoi vous arrêtez
voulait arrêter au sommet quoi ces
sabots il ya tout un tas de raisons y
assure personnel mais je voulais arrêter
au sol mais aujourd'hui j'ai fait une
carrière exceptionnelle je peux pas
faire plus j'ai inventé un métier qui
n'existaient pas pratiquement j'ai
ouvert les portes pour des femmes et et
puis voilà ça fait donc dix ans que je
t'aurais ça fait même quinze ans que
j'ai débuté et je suis au top niveau et
ça fait dix ans que je me maintiens
parmi les dix premiers du classement je
peux plus faire le plus et sortir en
pleine gloire
si vous avez votre fille aussi il faut
dire qu'ils sont de 3 ans qui s'appelle
sarah luna c'est ça tout à fait donc
j'ai pu vraiment le droit de me jouer
d'avis trop souvent bien donc je vous
promets que c'est que cette émission
réputé pour sa discrétion c'est tu ne
gagnes mendient combien de centimètres
je voulais dire simplement qu'on sera
discret sur la vie privée de marie sara
parce que cette émission 6100 discrète
on est des gens discrets gardez les au
taureau sexuelles et autres sections je
suis bon vous êtes alors dans le pôle
dire quand même la seule femme torero
août oreja au monde alors il ya eu des
femmes newton chute assez longtemps pour
les 30 dans les années 50 et j'ai été la
première femme qui a filmé carrière
vraiment internationale depuis quand tu
as in trône et il ya plein de jeunes
filles qui débute maintenant est
d'ailleurs la preuve en est à la feria
d'arles cette année il ya de nouvelles
jeune fille qui débute et donc j'ai
vraiment inventé une profession pour les
routes auraient à cheval parce que vous
dit effectivement que si une femme prend
un coup de corne dans dans le ventre
effectivement c'est sais c'est pas bien
pour enfanter plus tard et c'est pour ça
que la presse si vous avez un enfant
oui n'y a pas que ça et je crois que la
tauromachie à cheval est plus approprié
à la femme à pied c'est très très
violent il faut ça oblige la femme avant
une gestuelle très très masculine et il
ya une ambiguïté qui se fait plus le
spectacle n'est pas le même l'esthétisme
et non plus dire que les toreros ils
s'habillent un peu en dentelle avec avec
des perruques et où il s'habille en
femme les toreros c'est un peu travesti
en fin de compte si vous vous avez
quatre matches on est en tout si un
taureau qui lui la force masculine
montant que c'est vrai qu'il ya une
espèce d'ambiguïté qui avec un corps
d'homme nous dit je vous dit que vous
sentez le entre vos jambes le coeur du
du cheval battre quand le taureau
approche et tout c'est tout à fait
nouveau et c'est le plus beau de la
tournerie à cheval c'est arrivé à mener
ses chevaux dans le dressage et tout en
douceur
de tels exploits et être complètement
maîtres de la situation du riche en
artistes on leur donne des défaites et
artistique du charisme la personnalité
du rythme français le cheval qui rogne
entendu toro ici et il a joué il a dit
je vais jouer un beau mois sur un film
en espagne
tous les jours ouais j'ai eu une
expérience bonne savoir cet accord du
cheval entre les gens
je sentais plutôt fac non je sens un but
lutter je sentais un peu plus tôt mon
cul qui se ferait pas parce que j'ai
besoin d'argent
j'avertis marisa il parle comme ça mais
quand comprendrez-vous quand j'ai fait
un grand rêveur je fais un grand graveur
ne vouloir pas et d'essayer de pas
vouloir les stands de l'entrée rocky
prends ma place pour le grand pour l'eau
a pas de nouveaux lieux et le 20 km en
scène par le jeune homme est aussi le
plus là il met immédiat le côté sur ce
qu'on doit faire le film bravo avait un
doit finir le film donc je rentre ce
jeudi c'est toute façon c'est un grand
toro c'était 380 kg normalement c'est
pas les galons trop long mais ça peut
faire mal et donc je dis je m'habille
jeu mais je vais toute façon je vais le
tir et un peu tu fais la prise de vue et
je m'y tiens
si renault y apparaît avec un
mais il vient ici il voudrait pas ils
étaient ensemble et c'est bill a pas ce
qui m'attendait donc bon il faut que je
sors en milieu de tout le monde vous
attend au danger je crois qu'il dit
[ __ ] y'a aucun et les partis mais
venus de contre comme j'ai fait la pluie
miel comme ça c'est bien monsieur map
attraper la jambe et mais comme j'ai
perdu le truc rouge a pondu le troc rose
je me suis j'ai couru très vite
d'erreurs mentales d'un gameiro en effet
monsieur m'attraper il me courait
derrière comme un coureur mais c'est une
expérience terrible
on dit d'ailleurs c'est le cheval qui
porte les couilles mais vous vous
appelle quand même dounia corones ici on
vous a fait plein de dounia corones vous
dire or me demandez pas toujours de
traduire les trucs 1,3 d'image
moi je prends pas vénézuélien madame les
petites questions tout et les femmes en
espagne disent que c'est faire l'amour
avec un torero c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
les hommes y sont là ils pensent la même
chose vaut pour une tombe et là on pense
la même chose
vous pouvez aussi le saint le son du
taureau après les couilles mais ils font
ça ils font ça existe façon sinon ils
nous ont dit qu'ils font ça n'est ce pas
croire n'importe qui avalerait n'importe
quoi mais c'est sur youtube un voyage
est un peu plus soft mais savoir si vous
étiez déjà pris un coup de corne
non non surtout pour les gens beaucoup
de chutes parce qu'un cheval
effectivement le piaf et la chute
puisque l'autoroute peut faire tomber de
cheval tout simplement
alors j'ai eu pas mal de fracture mais
mes coups de cornes vraiment non il
avait déjà joué à intervilles s'est vu
demander l'animal terminant qu'elle
arrête qui ont cherché la france 3
france 3 voit la question
rocco siffredi pour et avec les
vachettes mais je rachète ue-mercosur
évocation c'était un coup de foudre
j'ai vu une corrida j'avais 14 ans il a
je suis sortie des arènes et j'ai décidé
que celle est ma vie c'est pas dans le
truc au départ vraiment voilà alors en
91 effet votre alternative en ckoi
l'alternative c'est quand devient
docteur en tauromachie en quelque sorte
d'accord on est reconnue donc par les
professionnels par le public et et on
rentre vraiment dans la cour des grands
un diamant sont asynchrones la quittes
qualité au mexique avait pu quitter plus
à parler de lien aussi le tramway
qu'avait dû appareils étaient plus
apparu en public depuis 40 ans
c'est la première fois qu'elles seront
montrées en plus pour elle donnait le
flambeau une autre c'était incroyable
puisqu'elle était très habitué 2000 toro
conchita c'est une
cd dans le camp des saints de 1000 de
toronto me reste un peu moins un peu
moins 2003 bon il l'a alors donc votre
carrière devient effectivement ce qu'on
sait et la suite fiso n'étant pas une je
vous ai promis des disques est même
obligée de le dire ce n'est pas méchant
vous rencontrer henri leconte fichent
ils viennent dire qu'elle aimait limites
bien fait et là où rencontrer henri
leconte et alors là quand on vous voit
on comprend remarquer henri leconte le
lendemain du jour de la rencontre et
vous demande de vous épousez quoi vous
demande votre main du taf et d'ailleurs
je l'épousé mais c'est fou a dit oui
tout de suite
c'était le coup de foudre c'était le
coup de foudre j'adore les coups de
foudre est dans cette émission est à peu
près un ou deux coups de foudre
lorsqu'il avait mal aux doigts c'est un
cas il faisait d'un futur alors bon et
là vous avez commencé aussi à triompher
non seulement dans les arènes mais dans
la presse people
et alors si l'affairé y en a presque
retrouvé le nom lui cédant
restant sur des journaux prestige armes
et surtout une vidéo qui est vraiment
d'ailleurs que je que je salue ici
passer d'un agent le magazine préféré
hot vidéo est aussi le père noël s'ils
sortent de terre comme cette vidéo mais
ce n'est pas son collier ou que tu ligne
il achète on peut lire c'est après donc
là vous êtes donc devenu effectivement
une star des médias disent on vous
appelez vite honnête non il forme
appelée reetone est considéré dans le
sud est de la france d'ailleurs à
saint-vincent-de-tyrosse
il s'était plutôt sympathique mes filles
me souviens plus tôt note est mignon et
là on vous jeter comme des balles de
tennis dans les arènes ça c'est pas dit
non mais c'était juste ce jour là et
alors vous êtes acheter un mât avec
henri leconte le niveau initial sur la
porte c'est vrai comme a comme à dallas
quoi c'est un nom comme andalousie
dalhousie comme en espagne 6e tradition
quand on arrive à jeunes chevaux de
mettre le faire de l'élevage sur la
porte
ce que j'ai appris ces miliciens et les
gens disent tiens c'est chez miss michel
sardou et lorsque j'ai appris c'est que
venait toréer chez vous à la grande
époque
christian clavier ça encore serge july
libération c'est le patron de libération
ne savait pas où il était le patron de
libération il allait chez vous faire de
la corrida au lien on y affecterait
quelques petites l'achète
heureusement qu'arlette laguiller puis
là avec ce que les gens à lui passera
savons là et alors là pour vous dit
après on en arrive à la fin de cette
interview parce que là vous dites il y
avait trop de paillettes je me suis dit
c'est un peu en livrée par par tout ça
quoi pas mais c'est à dire c'est pas
vraiment ça c'est que effectivement je
suis de toute façon décalage vont avec
avec mais la vie entre guillemets normal
parce que je vis dans un dans un monde
décalé vu que je suis dans un milieu
complètement fermée
sur les routes avec un milieu d'hommes
dans des on se retrouve dans des
villages pour rire forme andalousie pour
trouver une dans une corrida c'est
minable parce que ça c'est parti ça fait
partie du lot y'a pas que les grandes
arènes c'est vrai que quand on est
obligé de vivre cette vie là en plus on
ait besoin d'être concentré et ne pas
sortir de ce milieu là et et de
s'entraîner tous les jours moi je fais
six heures d'équitation par jour même
donc donc c'est vraiment une vie ont
d'ailleurs c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils me
virent là si vous avez une vie concentré
que le compte il faisait pas six heures
d'entraînement par jour là non pas du
tout et puis c'est vrai que ce décalage
avec la vie à près de tous les jours la
vie est compliquée et alors donc vous
êtes souvenu au moment de votre divorce
de ce que vous disiez votre grand-mère
magdeleine je suis pas divorcer oui mais
bon votre séparation les hommes sont
toujours de passage nous ça c'est ma
grand mère qu'elle disait avec moi je ne
dis pas je me suis souvenu mais je le
dis parce que je me réfère au stop il
voudra gabon dieu sport paris merci à
vous voyez on a été extrêmement discret
un jeu et à poser toutes les questions
qu'ils voulaient vraiment bouger quoi
vous mes boîtes du tout pas du tout
alors